le ministre doit décider d'ici
un mois, de donner ou non le feu
vert. Reportage.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une ville éclatante
avec ses décors
de carte postale...
... mais qui cachent
une certaine grisaille.
PlusieurPlusieurPlusieurPlusieu-
ville de Saint-Jean témoignent
des difficultés économiques
accentuées par la pandémie. Sur,
ce barbier d'expérience
constate le vide chaque jour.
Les affaires de son salon
tiennent à peu de choses.
Il a l'haccueillir
sur sa chaise des travailleurs
du pétrole, mais les clients
se font plus rares.
À l'autre bout de la ville,
dans cette usine de fabrication
qui a pour principal client
l'industrie pétrolière,
le bruit de la machinerie
résonne moins fort qu'avant.
Corey, un soudeur,
était constamment déployé
sur les plateformes.
Aujourd'hui, les sorties
en mer sont moins nombreuses.
Pour les travailleurs, c'est
l'attente et l'incertitude.
Mais au large, un espoir
se profile. La pétrolière
norvégienne Equino
l'approbation d'Ottawa pour
son projet Bay du Nord.
L'entreprise veut forer
un maximum de 60 puits à 500 km
au largeNeuve.
Le but : extraire de
300 millions à 1 milliard
de barils sur 30 ans, à compter
n de la décennie.
Ce qui pourrait représenter
l'équivalent de 7 ans de
consommation de pétrole
c.
Dans une province lourdement
endettée, où le ômage
était le plus élevé au Canada
le mois dernier, le projet
Bay du Nord est vu comme
une bouétage.
Terre-Neuve n'a pas
les moyens de s'en passer,
insiste le premier ministre.
Le projet représenterait
un minimum de 3,5 milliards
de dollars dans les coffres
de sa province et des milliers
d'emplois pendant
sa durée de vie.
Ce projet extracôtier
est présenté comme le plus
propre du Canada. Son empreinte
carbone liée à l'extraction
serait une fraction de celle
des sables bitumineux.
L'argument de vente
convaincra-t-il Ottawa?
rnement Trudeau
a jusqu'au 6 mars pour
donner le feu vert au projet.
STEVEN GUILBEAULT, ministre
fédéral de l'Environnement- Noue
de la réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
- Une décision déchirante pour
le ministre Steven Guilbeault,qr
un plafond au secteur pétrolier
au Canada et qui vient de se
fixer des objectifs climatiques
encore plus ambitieux.
Un hiver anormal
à Terre-Neuve-et-Labrador,
avec des côtes dénudées,
doit ser
selon cette militante.
SARAH SAUVÉ, militante, coop.
de justice sociale, T.-N.-L.
- Dans un monde où on est en
crise clon le voit
même ici, à Terre-Neuve,
il n'y a pas de neige,
on est au début février.
- Le moment est venu
age
et de diversifier l'économie
de la province, croit-elle.
- On le voit, ça fait des années
et des années qu'on a l'économie
pétrolière à Terre-Neuve
et c'est ce qu'on appelle
le "boom and bust".
On voit des grosses "booms",
mais aussi des super basses...
t'sais, des retours très bas,
puis il faut avoir d'autres
sources économiques
pour ne pas dépendre
seulement du pétrole.
- Outre ses émissions
de carbone, le projet
Bay du Nord soulè
craintes environnementales.
- On retrouve des anémones
de mer, des étoiles de mer,
certains crustacés...
- Même à plus ètresètresètresèts
sous la surface, là où
on procédera au forage,
la vie marine est très riche,
rappelle cette scientifique.
Dre ANNIE MERCIER,
Université Memorial, T.-N.-L.
- Mais il y a des champs
nges,
toutes sortes d'organismes,
finalement, qui non seulement
créent une biodiversité
benthique dans ces endroits,foir
des roles plus vastes,
notamment servir, par exemple,
de pouponnière à des poissons,
lesquels poissons fontl'objet d.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Déchets de forage, vibrations,
émissions sonores et risques
de déversements accidentels,
Bay du N
altérer des habitats
ainsi que nuire aux poissons,
aux mammifères marins et
eurs.
Malgré tout l'agence fédérale
d'évaluation d'impacts conclut
que le projet n'entraînera pasmx
négatifs importants.
Difficile de l'affirmer
avec certitude, selon
puisque nos connaissances
sur les milieux profonds
continuent d'évoluer.
- Je pense qu'un peu à l'image
deurs, c'est
plutôt obscur. Mais de dire
qu'on comprend l'ensemble,
qu'on comprend tous les tenants
et aboutissants de tousntiels i.
- Dans cette province en contact
si étroit avec la nature,
où le va-et-vient des navires
est intimement lié à l'activité
pétrolière, où l'industrie est
incrustée dans le paysage,
le dilemme est déchirant.
Corey mise sur ce
assurer son avenir et celui de
sa famille. Il craint de devoir
partir s'il ne se réalise pas.
Ici, tous se sentent
interpellés.
Deux courants,
l'un économique, l'autre
environnemental, alimentent
ce débat très sensible
Labrador.
♪ ♪ ♪
La décision que s'apprête à
prendre le gouvernement Trudeau
causera
des remo